most of the things that you are worried
about when it comes to sex your
performance your penis size your body
shape the way you're performing oral sex
your left boobs bigger than the right
baby whatever the things you're worried
about have like literally zero to do
with any sort of pleasure or
satisfaction and people will tell you
they have the best sex it was never
because of like the shape of the penis
the all these things it's about
connection it's about intimacy it's
about feeling safe it's about
experimenting it's about really being
with someone where you want them to have
the most pleasure and they want the same
for you
have you looked at how much sex people
are having in the modern world are we
having more or less sex than previous
generations apparently we're having less
sex than previous generations
media can't get enough of these studies
that they're doing that people are not
having sex the young people aren't
having sex
and it turns out people in relationships
are having the same amount of sex that
they've always had but younger
Generations are not doing it interesting
that's I mean that's one of the first
things that I learned when starting to
look at this which is almost all sex
it's something like 95 of sexual
activity within any given year occurs
only within relationships so people
think about The Singletons that are
spraying it all over the place and it's
not it's the people that are in
relationships that have almost all of
the sex it's true and it is that's been
that way for a long time it's just that
yeah like you said but people and people
aren't just out there dating as much or
they're not having sex as much and
they're just more you know Finding
satisfaction elsewhere and not
prioritizing it which is really
interesting
well it's less of a it's less of a sex
problem than it is a Singleton problem
in that case what about
okay what have you looked at to do with
the relationship between uh having sex
and people's happiness to people that
have regular access to physical touch
are they do they live longer are they
are they happier in other things
everyone who has more touch more sex
more connection are definitely happier
in life they report having more pleasure
more life satisfaction they live longer
you know touch is a requirement it
really is there's there's something
called Skin hunger and that's a real
condition that we need physical touch we
require it and as animals like we just
we want to cuddle we want to touch and I
think a lot of times we talk about sex
but something that I always talk about
is like sex is just part of it I think a
lot of times think we we think we're
craving sex and how we Define sex as
like penetration but really we're
craving intimacy and that could be
holding hands it could be kissing
cuddling massage you know but sometimes
you just if you are feeling lonely and
we know we also have a loneliness
epidemic and a sex epidemic apparently
but just getting a massage and finding
cuddling up holding a puppy we require
that as humans to thrive and it boosts
our serotonin our moods everything I
remember reading during the pandemic
about women who were touch starved or
touch isolated trying to find a way to
not risk covid but to also be able to
get a hug off of off a friend or off a
stranger and there were these support
groups for women on the internet who
hadn't touched another person for ages
and it was affecting their mental health
yeah no I'm sure I I didn't hear about
that one but I did have a massage
therapist call into my show during the
pandemic saying there was all these
women coming to him and they were like
you know asking for like a little
something extra a really happy happy
ending yeah
yeah see ya what a time to be alive
these are the real costs of the pandemic
I don't know about GDP and national debt
I want to know about the masseuses that
have to do Happy Endings that's what
we're about he wasn't complaining but
well yeah maybe
um one of the other things I'm British
right so our sensibilities when it comes
to opening up and talking about sex are
basically non-existent we're way too
stiff upper lips and stoic for that to
be the case what's happened in your
experience over the last since you began
researching this
around the conversation of of talking
about sex like are people more open or
less open are we having a Resurgence of
new Puritans at the moment you know it's
a great question because when I started
this almost 20 years ago there really
wasn't anybody talking about sex you
could really just point to Dr Ruth
and you know she was in her 90s now and
she started talking about sex probably
in the 80s
and there was a lot of resources people
weren't talking about it online now
since then there's definitely more
people there's more information
available online there's more podcasters
talking about I was definitely the first
podcaster talking about it
however so there's two things happening
yes we're more open and more comfortable
talking about sex you can buy a vibrator
at you know Walmart and and and you know
we see more nudity on television and
we're just more open right sexually
there's more TV shows with the word sex
entitled on Netflix which wasn't even a
thing five years ago however what hasn't
changed at all is that we still live in
a very pure technical Society where we
are just truly not comfortable getting
into the specifics around sex I mean if
you look at what's happening in like in
America with like Roe v Wade so now
we're like you know and then there's
also we're limiting sex education only
17 states require sex ed to be medically
accurate in America but yet we're
rolling back rights too so it's just
it's really pretty backwards that people
just don't have the information but yet
there's a proliferation of porn so now
we have all this pornography without sex
education and that's just lethal to be
honest because we know porn is not real
it's fiction someone wrote a script and
it's not how you accurately have sex so
there's a crisis in that sense that well
sex is ubiquitous and the internet and
you can see it when on your phone when
you're like eight years old kids are
seeing porn but yet they're going out in
the world having sex and there's not
information so it's not so in a way
there's we're in pretty much the same
place where people still don't have
information about pleasure which is what
I talk about a lot and I got to be
honest that even when I was my publisher
is probably going to kill me and I I I
but this is what it made me think of
that so I have a major publisher of my
books coming out smart sex
I don't know how to say this but they
really came at me in like December and
we're like we can't have sex in the
title because it's going to get buried
in the algorithms and I was like
I've been doing my show for 20 years to
make sex more accessible I have to put
sex in the title it's like I'm sex with
Emily so this is what we're up against
right it's still we live in a world we
are not as safe and comfortable talking
about sex right so if it's not the
sensibility that we have and the concern
that everyone has about opening up about
sex it's getting keywords hidden on the
Google search algorithm okay
um what is it have you ever looked at
why humans
are nervous about talking about sex just
generally why is that adaptive why would
that be an evolutionarily Adaptive
reason well because
evolutionary speaking I would say that
there was a time when we weren't but if
we go back about 500 000 years we look
at religion's impact on sexuality if we
look at the change in women's roles and
men's roles and how sex sort of became
more about procreation and women became
the property of men and we started to
police sexuality and so
um we didn't have a lot of again still
didn't have information about it and so
I think if we look at modern day why
we're not you know evolutionary speaking
I think there's been a lot of change in
it but even if you go back to Adam and
Eve which some people say that story
isn't even real Eve was blamed and
shamed for her body and what she did to
Adam making him take a bite of the Apple
so since the beginning of the time I
would say there's been some shame around
our genitals but if we fast forward to
modern day I can tell you that we
weren't even talking about sex in
America until about 50 years ago right
till the kids The Institute started
doing research around it and um in the
late 50s but so it's still a pretty new
field and even that they still I mean
even just yesterday I have a friend who
works at Kinsey's student said they were
being defunded so anyway there's that
there's also just shame I have to tell
you that there is so much shame around
our bodies and talking about sex and I
do think it goes back to more
conservative environments we don't have
information about it if you grew up in a
household where you were told it was
wrong to have sex in marriage or unless
you were married and that's sexually for
procreation
you know and without so I think a lot of
it is shame and we haven't normalized it
that our parents parents don't want to
talk to kids kids don't want to hear
their parents talk about it and a lot of
misinformation just leaves it shrouded
in mystery
one thing that
is interesting to add into that is that
I'm not convinced that the modern world
is as sex negative you know we've got
kids that are now 16 years old who were
born in what
2007. you know 2007 wasn't pitch burning
flag carrying you know like keep your I
mean women's gay marriage legalized not
long not too long after that right so it
seems like a relatively sex positive
world
yet
young people still have a lot of
reticence about talking about their sex
so you know there may be some of the
older people the older generation
perhaps my parents generation your
parents generation who who were
influenced by that conservative thinking
I'm not sure I wonder whether there's
just something more embedded I wonder
whether it's something about
I don't know the same way that you don't
talk to
your friends all the time about your
bowel movements or about your athlete's
foot or about like your chronic
flatulence or something whether there's
just something kind of sacred about or
not even sacred shameful inherently
shameful and I guess what you're trying
to do opening up the conversation about
sex normalizing it making it the sort of
thing that people don't need to blush
and look at the floor when they when
they discuss well you know I and I think
you're right I think there is some shame
out like I don't want it there's
things that we don't want it out but if
I didn't have an example of in the Dutch
countries like in the Netherlands it's
the only place that I know of and that
we've studied where they actually talk
about they start teaching sex
education when kids are very very young
like even when they're pre-verbal
meaning they name the body parts they'll
say those are your toes and your knees
and your thighs and your vagina your
vulva your penis whereas in America we
might skip right over and be like your
knees your thighs your stomach or your
private parts so
at a young age they start to normalize
that they name the parts they talk about
um consent when it comes to touching
like at a young age too they'll like say
this is your body and you have the right
to have people touch it or not and in
their sex education which they have
every single year as kids get older like
literally from kindergarten to to
graduation they talk about
um they talk about they have sex
education but where in America it's fear
it's basically don't get pregnant don't
get an STI basically don't have sex it's
all very mechanical and fear-based in
these Dutch countries they talk about
pleasure and they talk about orgasm and
they talk about yeah like consent and
asking for what you want and I think
that this lack of information here where
we don't really talk about the female
orgasm where there's like an orgasm gap
or there's all these missing things that
it just it just there's just a lot of
missing information here where we don't
talk about how it can be pleasurable and
great but again when you look at these
countries is they show that the
pregnancy rate is lower the parents the
kids talk to their parents about sex the
parents will say well if you had sex I
hope it was pleasurable I hope you had
an orgasm like that might seem so cringy
to everybody who's lived through this
but that's just because the way we were
socialized how much better is it to be
in a free open world like your parents
are like you're playing on a soccer
league like how was your match did you
win did you play it how was your sex did
you pleasure cool did you use protection
amazing what's for dinner like why does
it have to be so shameful right because
the the the the the problem with that is
that we walk around having pain faking
orgasms
um like I did for many many years
um about 80 of women have pain during
sex at some point in their life some
women always have pain but they never
talk about it we're like well I guess we
gotta have periods and give birth and
have pain during sex
um we don't there's an orgasm Gap where
men have orgasms and 99 of sexual
situations and women do not only 20 of
women have sex during during penetrative
sex
we you know women and men take between
like six and eight women so orgasm and
women take between 20 and 40 minutes so
like there's all these ways that if sex
is really supposed to be this
pleasurable collaborative effort where
we're all having a good [__] time
then it'd be so great to have
information about it so we could
actually do it in a way that feels good
so this is where the disconnect is like
yes people are having sex or they're
apparently not having sex but even when
they are having sex I think the quality
of sex hasn't changed and that is my
mission to be honest my mission is to
get people to have better sex and to and
everyone gets to decide what that looks
like and I don't even think that we know
what that looks like and so that's what
my mission is all about and what my book
is about that I just like literally it
was like I want people to know what's on
the menu and what sex even can look like
and here's all the tears of foundation
for knowing if you're sexually healthy
and what you need to know and then you
get to decide like here's everything
take what you like leave the fast but I
think right now since there's so much
disparate information we're just walking
around like why is sex so great at the
beginning of the relationship but it's
not great six months in or year in like
no let's just [__] deal with it and
have information and have a lot more
pleasure in our lives that's what I'm
all about
it is strange that we exist in a world
that's got more information than ever
before we've managed to eradicate
diseases we've mastered the climate we
can fly across countries we can do all
sorts of things communicate and yet
the quality of sex by the doctor as she
said doesn't seem to have improved you
know the quality of our lives have
improved by pretty much every other
objective metric that you care to care
about
um I wonder whether part of it is this
sort of current it is like a puritanical
world where people are focused so much
just on work and pleasure uh or
enjoyment feels
lazy it feels like unnecessarily
luxurious you probably don't have time
for it it's at the bottom of your list
of priorities mm-hmm exactly that's
exactly it and that's what I mean I this
this is my work is basically about
pleasure getting people to prioritize
pleasure and not put conditions on
Pleasure like it's only once I work out
could I have dessert or once I check
everything off my list can I go do
something that's fun for me and my
thesis hypothesis that really that sex
that sex well that pleasure is
productive that the more pleasure you
have the more pleasure you work into
your life your schedule your planning
you know as you're planning your
workouts or your times with friends or
all the other things you're prioritizing
put pleasure on the map put pleasure on
your calendar like whatever that is and
I actually have in my book a a pleasure
percentage that I help people figure out
like their pleasure formula of how many
if you look it up there's like a formula
of how many minutes in the day how many
minutes in the week and you divide it up
and you figure out like all the the
formula literally for how you can insert
pleasure into your life and like look
ahead and be like these are the things
that make me me feel good because
otherwise they just don't happen to your
point you're just like I don't deserve
it I didn't do enough and the next thing
you know like weeks go by months go by
you're like when was last time I did
something that was just fun for me what
is fun
like what is pleasure really yeah we
work on so much we all work so hard and
we we're on our phones we're on our lap
like we're always available
but we're not we're not scheduling in
we're not scheduling that pleasure time
okay you said you said before something
that's an interesting question which is
why is sex so exciting at the beginning
of a relationship and why does it Wane
over time what have you come to believe
about that Well I this is the there are
biology speaking there's something
called the honeymoon phase which is a
real cycle a biological condition less
anywhere from six months to two years
and what they show is that you know when
something's new and exciting and we you
know the novelty of being someone new we
actually have looked at the brainwave
patterns of people falling in love or in
lust and it's it's it's it looks like
the people on cocaine like if you look
at people falling in love and lust it's
the same exact thing you've got the
dopamine the serotonin that's the most
delicious cocktail of feel-good hormones
flying around and we feel amazing but
just like everything that feels great it
also has to come down right it comes up
it comes down so then it stagnates and
then we're like okay well I'm not riding
the waves of the fumes of the newness
and excitement meant what do we do about
it how do we keep it going and what we
do crave after this period is you know
if we start the sex started Flatline is
we do crave like novelty and newness and
variety and so you know but that's why
that's why it happens and then that's
when people usually come to find me when
we're like okay
now what do we do and since we don't
have a lot of information about sex and
we're not comfortable talking about sex
and we can compartmentalize sex we
really do we kind of put it over there
we're like let's close my eyes get naked
and hope for the best hope it's good and
then when it's not good we don't know
what the [__] to do so I help people
kind of figure out what they can do to
make it keep it hot keep it interesting
keep it fresh and keep it going pivoting
from that I think it's the passionate to
the companionate those are the two
systems in Eve psych speak and uh you
have the one that is all-encompassing
you're concerned about why they've
waited so long to text you back you
can't wait to see them again it ruins
your day because you can't not think
about them and then things do pivot but
they pivot for an Adaptive reason right
that you go from mate retention to
family building you're no longer focused
as much on trying to be obsessive to
make sure that they're invested in you
you're both invested in each other and
now we need to move forward but I
imagined that given that pleasure is
something that needs to be prioritized
given that it's something that
determines our quality of life it makes
us live longer etc etc
these two things almost kind of work
against each other so one of the most
common Dynamics I think that people will
see especially those that are in
relationships are sex becoming
routinized the the type of sex that you
have when you have it where you have it
the way you have it how long it lasts
the things you do
what are your pieces of advice for
people who feel like sex is
the same as a trip to McDonald's now I
know my order I know what to expect I
know how long the wait's going to be and
I know what I'm going to feel like after
I finished
what should you do well I think the
first thing to do is to if you're in a
relationship is to start to talk to your
partner about sex really my whole thing
is communication is a lubrication and
the more that we talk about sex the
better sex we're gonna have so really
it's finding out
what
what kind of sex do we like having
what's interesting to us like let's do a
little bit of research a little bit of
digging a little bit of reflective you
know talking about what has worked in
our relationship and what hasn't so
you can talk about for example
okay so here's the thing
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
the majority of people in long-term
relationships haven't really talked
about their sex life in a way that is
useful in a way that can help them
answer this question of what can we do
to keep it hot and interesting and so
you know I actually in in this book
smart sex I write about these five
pillars which are sort of the foundation
and the tools of the way that people can
check in with themselves and understand
their own sexuality because when I
started writing this book it was like
okay I've got 20 years of knowledge
here's all my best tips and tricks
and then I thought like you know
everybody wants a quick fix when it
comes to sex like what's the toy what's
the lube What's the sex position and I
give that like I give that in droves and
smart sex I literally put everything in
there but then I realized that people
really need an organizing principle
around sex I want people to understand
there are five pillars and that's going
to help them understand
who they are as a sexual being they
don't see the relationship between their
sexual being their emotional being their
mental well-being their physical
well-being their spirituality their
their
um you know their self-confidence or
self-acceptance all the things so
there's all these factors that come into
play so when I tell couples to talk
about their sex life there's a lot of
different things going on there's all
the tips and tricks like try this
position try this toy but then there's
what's going on with the individual with
with you and I really feel like I what I
said I was people what I help people do
is understand who they are sexually so
then they can relate to a partner and
they can figure out these like five
pillars together for example like what
like the first one is is embodiment
right how in our body are we during sex
do I know what makes me feel when I'm
having sex with someone am I present am
I feeling my partner's body my hands do
I do I you know feel my feet on the
ground like in any moment how embodied
are you is this a conversation when it
comes to embodiment in these five
pillars is this something that someone's
supposed to approach with a partner is
this a is it best to do it with a
partner is it best to journal it is this
supposed to be part of my morning
meditation practice what am I doing I
love this that you're asking this so I
think so I mean because I'm getting into
the pillars out but really for couples
this is just well first of all there's a
text IQ quiz if you can take on my
website it's like a figure out where
you're at and where to start but I do
this I if I'm not in the mood for sex or
I don't want something I write down the
five areas and I think about an out
Journal at the top of my my notes my
phone and I go around I'm like have I
paid attention to all of these pillars
do I how's my health and wellness have I
been working out what's my blood flow
like have I been communicating with my
partner that's another one of the
pillars is collaboration have I talked
to you about what my turn-ons are what
makes me feel good in the bedroom what
doesn't maybe I have some resentments
too so you're just a way of kind of
analyzing where you're at say your
sexual health and then you know figuring
out then then talking apart about it so
so really it's just yeah you could do
this on your own you could read this
with your partner you could figure out
like what so the first thing is I have
and if you want to start more like at a
base level like if you're in a
relationship with someone and you've
never talked about your sex life a great
place to start like if we're just
talking quickly like if before we get
into the psychological and emotional
part of it and you're like right now I
want to know what's going on talk about
the three most memorable times you've
had sex with each other not with
somebody else but be like what's our
most memorable times we have sex and
then you look at that and you think
okay what is what what was happening in
those moments what why was it so great
was there a new sex move was it was
there a lot of foreplay was there a lot
of build up had we not seen each other
in a while was there a lot of oral sex
what did someone almost walk in the room
and we thought we almost got caught like
what elements were happening so we can
kind of reverse engineer what great sex
feels like when did we feel the most
connected what was happening
so that's a great place to start
I have a yes no maybe list on my site
that lists all of like the 80 sex acts
out there that couples can kind of take
a little quiz together and figure this
is more like what what are we into are
we into kissing spanking dirty talk like
what would be great but at the end of
the day Chris at the end of the day we
have to understand when do I get turned
on when do I get aroused what time of
month what time of day what conditions
need to be present for my arousal do I
need to have it like if it's freezing in
my house and it's a mess I am shut down
I have no blood flow I'm freezing I'm
shivering I can't relax because the
dishes are in the sink if I'm resentful
with my partner because he hasn't like
he didn't come home he said he was going
to or we got in a fight last week like
there's no way that I'm in the mood for
sex if I'm in pain if I'm having my
period if I'm right so there's just and
we don't we just think it's a magical
switch that's going to flip on at any
moment because it did early on in the
relationship so through this book
through these pillars you can learn at
any time it's kind of like your health
if you're not feeling in shape you don't
just go to the J if you let's say you
want to get in shape right you have to
just go to the gym you're going to like
if you want to be healthy right you're
going to go to the gym you're going to
change your diet you're going to get
your blood work done maybe you're going
to amp your Connections in your
community and try to have your mental
health so the sex is the same way but
since we compartmentalize it we're
disconnected from it I don't feel to
realize it's there's a holistic approach
to understanding your overall wellness
and that includes your sexual health
[__] blocked by the dishwasher what a
scenario to get yourself into yeah I
think I think that you're right you know
not being intentional about sex is
um something that's super common it's
tied into by this Shame by the fact that
it's more difficult to speak to other
people about you know you're not gonna
I applaud you and I thoroughly hope that
people can have a more uh organic
relationship with talking about sex but
I don't see a world in which I want to
open up to my mom about whatever's going
on in my sex life so you know given the
fact that that's the case it is one of
the more challenging things for you to
do
um
talking about stuff that gets in the way
what are the most common emotions that
get in the way or stop people from
having pleasure
um
on the things that get in the way of
pleasure
so I call these the pleasure thieves and
the first one is stress
anxiety stress worry
if we're at a place where we are worried
all the time and anxious and we're in
our heads and we're worried about money
our jobs Our Lives we we're not going to
be able to prioritize our pleasure and
make as much time for it we're going to
be in our heads which means we're not in
our bodies so that's that's just a huge
factor and again I think that people
don't often see that connection between
their lifestyle and their mental health
and their sexuality there's also shame
as we covered that if we have shame
around our bodies around our sexuality
around how we show up thinking that we
shouldn't be having sex it's going to be
really hard to have connected
intentional sex it really is and then
trauma if we have unhealed trauma
any kind of trauma big tea trauma Little
T trauma that our body is in fight or
flight and we are disassociate during
sex also going to make it difficult for
having sex
those are some of the things all of
these uh well no trauma trauma to me
feels like something especially Big T
trauma is the sort of thing that it's
not just enough to speak to your partner
about right you probably won't be going
there yeah
listen we all need therapy we all need I
believe that we all could use therapy at
some point in our life I mean it's just
like getting a second opinion on your
life we do it in our business right we
get a business coach or your car breaks
down we go to the mechanic like if our
relationship or our mental health it
just it just yeah I'm just a huge fan of
therapy I really can't even believe it's
something that people still don't
realize that they could use and it
doesn't have to be like a traditional
once a week therapist people can find
other ways to kind of do that internal
work I just think it's so important I
mean another thing that's really keeping
us from pleasure is medications I don't
think that we realize that
antidepressants birth control pills
um some blood pressure medications will
directly impact our libido our blood
flow
our ability to get aroused turned on
erect lubricated wet and so again the
disconnect with lack of information I
mean nobody's reading the side effects
on the side of a pill bottle but they
probably should or maybe they heard it
and they're like oh but it doesn't
really affect me it absolutely does and
these are also things we have to pay
attention to so you can talk to your
doctor about it your medical doctor and
you can say I'm not okay with these side
effects are there other things that I
can do these ssris are causing me to be
basically impotent have you had Dr Sarah
Hill on your show no lady that wrote
this is your brain on birth control
no but I've had a few other birth
control people on but I'll no I haven't
but I'll write it down it'll be similar
stuff to what you've seen but she's
phenomenal and she looks at it through
an evolutionary lens which is great and
she's got some ovulatory window shift
stuff in there which is which is
interesting too but they did a study
with natural cycles you know the
thermometer under the tongue people so
they actually worked with the company to
have an in-app study that was done
all of the women who are on the natural
cycles app are currently off birth
control because why the [__] would you
be tracking a cycle on birth control
right they surveyed a bunch of the users
and asked whether whether they met their
partner when they were on birth control
or when they were off birth control they
then asked them to rate their current
level of sexual satisfaction with their
partner and I think in the app there is
a journal entry that asks you to put
your current level of arousal or like
sexual desire or something like that
they were then able to compare the level
of sexual satisfaction from women that
had met their Partners when they were on
and are now off or met their Partners
when they were off and are now still off
women who met their Partners when they
were on birth control and are now off
had a lower level of sexual satisfaction
with their partner but both groups had
the same level of sexual desire and
arousal so no difference in terms of sex
drive but a marked difference in terms
of how much they were attracted to their
partner and you go okay has anybody ever
told any girl ever when they go to go
and get birth control at age 16 or
something beware that the partner that
you end up with if you then decide to
get off birth control maybe you're
married maybe you've been together for
four or five years and you've never
released yourself from this
hormone-induced stupor and you go
holy [__] I'm in a relationship with
somebody that
I'm not that sexually compatible with
when I don't have a ton of progesterone
flowing through me
um it really really it's like terrifying
and fascinating yeah no it is I actually
talk about the study in the book and I
didn't know I think it was I wonder if
it was the same study with Sarah hell I
don't I don't know that that's the name
of it but I this is a known study that's
been around that we do talk about a lot
that it's just there are so many factors
that when women take a birth control
pill at 16 17 they don't realize that
it's going to impact their that they're
more at risk for depression for anxiety
um for yeah reduce libido for
concentration problems diet for their
for their you know just everything
I mean I just yeah I mean I took the
pill for a year I don't remember and it
was almost like a non-pill like back now
there's more information this is why I'm
so thrilled there's so many of them
talking about this but I remember going
to the doctor I was on it for like you
know 10 years and they'd be like are you
on any medication Maybe not just the
pill like it was never no one ever
talked about side effects ever it was
just that's what you do you don't talk I
mean it's just crazy to think now with
all the information we have how harmful
it is well that's that's one of the
pieces of advice that I definitely give
to people which is if you and your
partner are thinking about getting
married and your misses has been on
birth control for the entirety of your
relationship you you really really need
to get her to come off this before you
commit to buying the house getting the
dog doing the marriage starting the
family
because and it's brutal to say like you
know we are inexorably linked our
psychology and our biology work in
tandem with each other and you just
don't know how different the texture of
your partner's mind could be if she
comes off birth control and you go [__]
like this doesn't work and and it's a
non-zero number it's like not an
insignificant number of people to whom
this happens so yeah I think that's
important so going back to the
communication thing someone's listening
to this and they go
that's me and my misses I we we don't
talk about sex as openly as we should do
this sex IQ thing sounds like I I've
never even considered it
what is the best process for beginning a
conversation opening up this world of
talking about sex with your partner
find a space and time to talk about it I
talk about the three T's of
communication I have a communication
guide on my site it's like timing tone
and turf I mean this is a great tool for
any kind of sexual conversation that you
want to have but you want to make sure
that you are first off that you're
entering any of these conversations from
a place of curiosity and compassion and
being intentional that this conversation
is going to be about our collaboration
and about us coming together in a place
where we want to learn more about each
other rather than defensive like why
don't you ever hit why don't you ever go
down on me why aren't you initiating sex
there's so much anger and hostility
around sex so timing tone interface pick
a time when you guys are hanging out and
it's chill it's not when you are you
know not any good chills but it's like
now when you've been like fighting or
whatever it's like date night and the
time you're saying that immediately
after a rampant argument saying why'd
you never go down on me that's terrible
it does never receive well people but
then they throw over there
people throw it in man they throw it in
at the times that you shouldn't and then
the turf that's the most important thing
to remember is it's outside the bedroom
people do not have these kind of
conversations when you are in the
bedroom uh when you are in a heightened
state of arousal already or you're upset
about something I would just love
everybody to keep their bedrooms before
sleeping and for sex
uh what about tone
the tone is light and curious and it's
open and it's it's collaborative and I
give a lot of tools in the book for
actually I mean I give scripts upon
scripts because what I know after 20
years that people are like I still don't
know how to do it like even though I
talk about timing tone and turf like
it's a light it's open you're not
defensive you're learning how to be you
know I some active listening tools for
people to learn to how to actually
reflective listen a lot of us we just
don't listen we talk and we don't
actually hear what our partner's saying
so there's methods to repeating back to
what your partner says to make sure that
you are hearing each other and the other
thing to remember is that it's not a
one-time conversation my vision is for
couples to have this conversation all
all the time I mean you're just giving
yeah yeah it doesn't have to do when
your parents are on the table but when
you're like you know yeah wherever
because like you talk about date night
right like what are we gonna do tonight
where are we going to go on our vacation
what what don't you talk about your own
personal goals or your work go I know my
partner I talk a lot about like what our
goals are professionally and personally
and health goals and all those things
but like we talk about our sex life like
we're like okay we're going away what
what Toys should we bring what should we
do what's our like thing that we're into
this week this month should we like I
know when there's times that I'm turned
on or not or he's like should we have
sex we literally talk about and it's so
hot because it's not confused there's no
confusion around my sexuality there's no
like resentments or are we gonna have
sex We're not gonna have sex because
we're like just like are we ordering in
are we cooking dinner are we having sex
are we not like and then we clear all
the confusion and upset stuff around sex
the weirdness and the things that we
just know like when we want to do it
it's kind of like going to the gym you
know like for your workouts you optimize
it like a great hack is to put your
shoes out the night before sign up for
your class have a trainer keep yourself
accountable is that what you're saying
that you leave you leave cues around the
house so the butt plug is next to the
NutriBullet just in case
my assistant charges my sex toys I'm not
kidding you they're always ready to go
right I hope that you pay your assistant
unbelievably well they're already clean
she just turns them yeah but she
organizes my whole life she charges my
laptop she charges my iPad she oh yeah
everyone here she's got a doc we've got
everything we've got the airpods we've
got the butt plug we've got everything
in the nice clean line yeah
get Tactical for a second what a what
are some of the favorite scripts that
you have for how somebody should Broach
a discussion about sex with their
partner
uh see one of my favorite ways to do it
is once we because that timing tone and
turf conversation could just be hey
I realize we've never talked about our
sex life I was listening to this great
podcast and they said that couples who
talk about sex actually have better sex
so because it's because literally you're
like if I you have to remember this when
you approach your partner if you've
never talked about sex
there's a pretty good chance they're
going to go into fight or flight they're
going to be like why are you bringing
this up to me what am I doing wrong oh
my God my penis really is as small as I
thought or not as hard or not oh you
don't like my breasts there's just a
million things we go to this place not
like oh great you want to talk about our
sex life that is I've been waiting for
that too babe no it's usually met with
like animosity and fear
so that's why the tone is so important
and the timing and just saying listen I
realize that this is something that you
know we haven't talked about but I want
to have a growth mindset around our sex
life and I hope that you do too I hope
that this can be a place where we can
grow and learn together and evolve you
know would you be down for that so
that's just that's just the general
conversation but let's say there's
something that you really want to
you know you want to give feedback too
you want to give some constructive
feedback I love the compliment sandwich
the sexual compliment sandwiches when
you start with you know a compliment you
start with something that you'll really
love about the sex life like oh God last
night was so hot I love when you you
know maybe my desire is to kiss more
right do you know that in long-term
relationships kissing is one of the
first things that goes we stop kissing
we stop making out remember like early
on like you have those long makeup
sessions and sex that's a lot longer
well maybe I've learned that kissing is
a big part of my arousal process so I
would say you know I really love the sex
we're having it was so hot last I love
the way like you solely and dressed me
and it was so the orgasms and it was um
that butt plug you really like used that
really well last night babe but I
realized and this is when you get to the
constructive part is that you know I
really miss our kissing and for me I
know we kiss a little bit at the
beginning but I think it would be so
hard if we could kind of bring back in
some of those makeout sessions and then
you end it with why it would be great
for both of you because I think the more
we kiss the more connected we're gonna
feel and I know I'll be way more turned
on and down for more sex
so you just sort of yeah well one of the
things
I guess almost everybody has performance
anxiety in one regard or another right
guys for how long they can last and
girls for whether or not they're doing
it right and I think that trying to work
out a way to dampen The Landing to to
just make it a little bit more gentle is
is probably pretty important because you
don't want to trigger a response in
somebody that worsens the situation I
think that that's one of the reasons
that people fear bringing this up is
well how's my partner going to respond
exactly I'm trying to improve our sex
but what if I make it worse what if I
make them more self-conscious yeah well
I think that if you if you're in a
relationship where you can be super
vulnerable about your insecurities and
your challenges and you know I hope I
mean my hope that everyone's in a
relationship where they can they're able
to talk about other areas like oh my
boss at work didn't treat me you know so
so well today or I'm feeling you know I
didn't get that raise or I didn't get
that thing and You're vulnerable but sex
is the same way so if you have Instagram
hopefully your partner is coming it from
like a loving in place like if you're
giving feedback and you're trying to
grow into the sex life and try to evolve
it so it's interesting and hot for both
of you that we can take some of the
shame and trust and know that your
partner is with you because they love
you and they're attracted to you and
they find you sexy and hot and that all
the things that I want people to take a
moment here and really hear what I'm
saying that most of the things that you
are worried about when it comes to sex
your performance your penis size your
body shape the way you're doing giving
performing oral sex the way your breasts
your left boobs bigger than the right
baby but whatever the things you're
worried about have like literally zero
to do with any sort of pleasure or
satisfaction and people will tell you
they have the best sex it was never
because of like the shape of the penis
the all these things it's about
connection it's about intimacy it's
about feeling safe it's about
experimenting it's about really being
with someone where you want them to have
the most pleasure and they want the same
for you it's a collaboration it's a
beautiful dance and so if I can leave
this planet and let have people realize
that like
all of this is okay you're normal your
fantasies your desires it's all fine
that you have to make peace with
yourself and then find a partner that's
open to collaborate with you on this and
have these conversations like that's the
biggest roadblocks is our own fears
around sex and worry what are you
hearing from women about what they wish
that their Partners would do more or
less of in the bedroom I'm aware that
this isn't a one-size-fits-all I'm aware
that every woman's body and fantasies
are individual but are there some common
trends that you're hearing from women
about things that are commonly do's and
don'ts more than lesses
um
say that
they knew that women want more they want
sex to be slower
I say they go five times slower than you
think
slow everything down
kissing undressing making out if you're
going down on your partner like don't be
like the one like Wonder stayed down
there a little bit longer if you heard
me earlier it takes women anywhere
between 20 and 40 minutes to orgasm I
think that women want slowness I think
they want intentionality they want
compliments they want to feel adored
they want to feel worshiped they want to
feel beautiful compliments go a long way
the brain is our largest sex organ so
you know besides our skin people always
get on me for that but find our skin
also is important you know so I think
that the more that we can connect
sexually I often say foreplay all day or
foreplay starts after the last orgasm so
what can you do in the times in between
sex to stay connected and hot and keep
it sexy whether it's like sexting
sending pictures telling your partner
what you want to do next what you
remember about the last time you had sex
keeping sex top of mind keeping your
pilot light lit because when you just
like think about I'm always gonna use
the analogy at the gym like you start
working out every day you're feeling
great right and then you don't go for a
while you don't go for a month and it's
a lot harder to get back in there the
same thing goes for sex so I think that
we all not just women remember we want
to keep that fire going we want to keep
it lit so I think that I just hear that
we want more like we don't want to just
be going about our lives and then
there's this expectation we should just
want to go and have sex because our
partner does so I think that we have to
remember that women are slow cookers
typically and men are like frying pans
so if you can just remember that that
we've got more bells and whistles and
buttons and things that have to happen
for us to be aroused again not one size
fit all there's some women who feel
differently but overall in my 20 years
of work this is what I've found that we
need a little bit more
a little bit more of everything to keep
us to keep it to keep it hot and keep it
interesting and collaborative
you mentioned about instigating sex and
I think that initiating sex from you
know all of the I used to run an event
business so I saw a lot of 18 to 25 year
olds that were in and out of
relationships making up and breaking up
and stuff like that and one of the most
common disagreements that was had around
sex
seemed to be who was initiating it how
it was initiated communication about
about trying to start it a lot of the
time I think girls
not instigating which can sometimes
cause guys to feel not desired that's
kind of a bit of a lame thing for a guy
to admit to because you go well if I
don't feel desired that what even is
that that's kind of a bit of a feminine
trait that undermines my masculine
confidence and Essence that makes me
less of an alpha or a high value man
um what if you come to believe or learn
about instigating sex
philosophically tactically what do you
think I think that we all need to
initiate and integrate sex I think that
it has to be a two-way street I think
that there's
I also want to say that I get why
usually in relationship there's one
person initiates more than the other
that's just how it is usually there's a
high desire partner and a low desire
partner and typically those people get
together in a relationship and so one
person's always initiating but what
happens is there's just this yeah what
happens is that then they get into this
challenge where if you're always the one
who's driving if you think it gets
exhausting you're not even sure that
your partner wants to and then they're
the one who has the power the low desire
partner has the power in the
relationship they're the one who's
deciding is the second going to happen
is the sex not gonna happen so that
could be exhausting too to be like well
why am I not desired am I not wired why
aren't you you know making an effort but
I think again like everything we get
into these patterns right we get into
patterns and we're like well this is how
our sex happens you make the move and I
follow but the challenge around it is
yeah someone feels rejected they feel
like they're doing all the work they
don't know that they're desired and it
does seem like it's a feminine thing but
we all have feelings and emotions and
want to feel loved and adored and safe
that is just blurs across gender lines
so the thing about initiation is
it's really important to realize that
it's a skill set that you might not be
as used to it you might not have done it
you might not know what it looks like
but it's okay to tell your partner too
because these are the kind of
conversations I want people to have
I know that you want me to initiate more
I mean this could be one of our
conversations if you're in a
relationship and say you know I feel
like babe I know I love the sex that
we're having but I feel like I'm always
making the effort and I would love to
know that you're down with sex too
doesn't ever just strike you don't you
ever just want to grab me like I grab
you like I see you I walk in the door
and I want to throw you down on the bed
but you never do that to me and I would
just love if you did would you be done
with that right but you do it in a much
more you wouldn't say never and you
would do a different way however the
problem is I might hear that and to be
honest I will be real You're vulnerable
I'm not the initiator as much in my
entire sexual history I typically rely
on my partner to initiate
but I've had People Partners say to me
you know again it's my life work but
still I need to initiate so what I've
realized is that what I need to do is
it's just not in my habit I don't get
struck by it like like my guys do that
I'm with
um I'm just not that person I am
somebody who is more responsive I
respond to stimuli so there's like we
get there's people who are spontaneous
arousal and responsive arousal and again
I hate to do this stuff with gender but
usually men are more spontaneous and
women tend to be more responsive so I'm
responding to my partner's kids on my
neck he came and he grabbed me he did
something he sent me sexy text I'm
responding to that okay so knowing that
about myself and my partner saying he
wants to initiate more I had to then do
a trip in my brain and say okay
since I know it's not going to strike me
over that I have to think about
when am I going to initiate and then
I'll plan it I'm like okay well I know
that the house has to be clean the
dishes have to be the dishwasher it has
to be warm I have to have worked out
feel good showered the bed has to be
made my toys are charged the Lube's out
right I mean there's things that need to
happen I I don't want to do it early in
the morning because I don't want to miss
my workout I got to get up and work out
so like there and I think that in saying
this hopefully people are thinking about
this too because what I encourage what
smart sex is all about is about getting
smart about your arousal your desire so
you can hack it and you know like this
is exactly what needs to happen so then
I have to think about it so that's one
thing I'm like these are all things that
happen and then literally another thing
to do is saying to your part if you're
still like but I still can't do it I
still can't initiate another piece of
advice I give is ask your partner I
thanks for letting me know babe I know
you want me initiate more what would
that look like to you what would a
really hot initiation look like because
maybe my head's the imperfections I'm
thinking has to be like some elaborate
thing where I'm like naked on the bed
wearing lingerie with rose petals
everywhere right and maybe I invited up
another woman over like I don't know
what's hot if that's your fantasy who
knows
but literally you might be like I just
want you to um grab me and just kiss me
I just want you to make out with me I
want you to come behind me kitchen put
your arms around me I want you to send
me a naked photo like and then I have
some fodder then I know I'm like oh
that's easy right and then it's less
fearful it's less scary it becomes a
habitator then you realize that's no big
deal it's literally no big deal I did it
and I'm done let's move on to some other
sex problems so it's really again I just
try to get into the Nuance nitty-gritty
of where people get stuck and that's
what after all these years I realize
this is a really common thing the
initiation thing is huge and the thing
is it might not sound like it's a big
deal but when you realize that you when
you think you're the only one pulling
the sexual weight in a relationship
it builds into resentments then those
resentments get out of control and
there's a lot happening so like let's
just nip it in the bud the second you
start having sex with someone is when
you should start talking about all of
these things right if you haven't yet
that's cool too but start to understand
who you are as a sexual being
here's something else that I noticed a
lot especially throughout my 20s which
was conversations uh that I had with
some of my close guy mates about how
it was always expected and almost
resented I think sometimes from the
girls if they weren't hot to trot at all
times that there is an expectation that
the man is the sexual protagonist and
that the woman is the sexual gatekeeper
and she's going to respond
when you are forthcoming but that if the
reverse happens and you're not
immediately just ready to go or you
don't fancy it this evening or you are
whatever that that's much more accepted
typically from the woman you know you've
seen it in a million comedy shows if the
guy rolls over and tries to sort of
fondle with the girl and she's like I'm
babe I'm sleeping I'm tired tonight I'm
on my period I'm a blah blah but the
reverse I don't think that we have a
particularly good positioning for guys
there's a lot of Shame around that
around fine you know what it is like
I've had a hard day at work like I don't
want to do this but if I say no maybe
initiation is rarer uh maybe it makes me
feel like less of a man maybe I've got
concerns about performance if I do try
to have sex during a time when I'm not
as in the mood for it uh that's that's
something that I think is a lot less
talked about yeah absolutely and I love
that you're bringing that up because I
want to normalize that too I mean my
heart goes out to men men have so much
pressure they're supposed to be turned
on ready to go hard erect making the
moves and then knowing what exactly what
they're doing to turn their partner on
and doing all the tips and tricks and
sometimes guys are not in the mood for
sex just as much as women are and in
fact I found again to go back to to this
that I've hear from just as many women
who want more sex than their male
Partners so I just want to normalize
that as well that that's really really
really common and so
um yeah just having compassionate for
your partner if they don't want it again
this is where the normalizing the sex
conversation comes in if if in just
understanding that just because your
partner doesn't want to have sex tonight
it can be not tonight it doesn't mean
not ever it doesn't mean that now and
then putting some words around and say
babe you know what I tonight I've had a
long day I'm not feeling it but I can't
wait for this weekend like Saturday
night like let's do something let's go
out just the two of us so then your
partner's feeling a little bit less you
know rejected or less you know attached
to that outcome I just think that we
don't again put words around and then we
get to we create all these stories you
know in our head if we could just kind
of say not now we're just like
here's why and let's talk about it later
let's do it later
looking at the reverse of this what are
the most common reasons that you hear
from women about why they're not
reaching orgasm during sex
usually well during penetration if we
talk about that
penetrative sex typically does not hit
women where they need to be hit there
are clitorises external and internal but
the orgasm starts with the clitoris
being
um you know the most common orgasm is a
clitoral orgasm which is you know women
being taught usually the majority of
orgasms are going to happen from a
fingers a mouth or toys that's how the
female orgasm happens so women aren't
having orgasms when we when it's just
penetration without any foreplay or
orgasm or pleasure or stimulating the
clitoris beforehand because you're just
missing all the hot spots like the inner
third of the woman's vagina is the most
sensitive and so those are some of the
areas we need to pay attention to and so
that's one reason is that we're just we
don't really know how to advocate for
that we don't know how to move during
sex now penetrative sex could elicit an
orgasm if we had more stimulation first
if we use the toy if we used fingers you
know then we could have one in
conjunction with penetration so I would
say just a really about understanding
our anatomy and how it all works is one
factor
um another thing is yeah just like it's
not having well it's kind of the same
thing but not having enough
build up not having enough arousal not
having enough foreplay and then it could
be also medications birth control pill
never here's another one never having
one before with a partner but just
having one during masturbation so that's
like a new you know everyone's body is
different so it's not feeling safe with
a partner not feeling that I'm with a
partner that I can actually communicate
my needs and let them know that this
these are the steps that need to happen
so one of the one of the most
interesting stuff that I'd seen about
this was
initiated by the declining rates of not
having an orgasm compared with how many
times you've had sex with that person so
I think it's like 80 percent of women
don't have sex on the first date or the
first time that they have sex not on the
first date uh and then it like
relatively reliably declines as you get
with somebody more now there's something
going on you know physically you can
start to communicate more about
compatibility and blah blah blah but
really what that suggests is that it's
more about Comfort it's more about
feeling relaxed it's more about being
um
comfortable with the partner that you're
with and I saw a really fascinating
study this is a little while ago now
that said the most common reason for
women not reaching climax during sex was
recursive self thoughts about not
reaching climax during sex
yeah our head was absolutely that makes
yeah we're in our heads performance
anxiety am I not going to orgasm I'm not
going to orgasm I think I'm going to
orgasm is not going to happen so
absolutely and the same thing goes for
men and their erections or their orgasm
the same thing am I going to get hard am
I going to come too quickly oh [__] am I
going to come so yes when we are in our
heads during sex the blood is leaving
our genitals and going through our
brains to fuel all of these thoughts
that are not serving us and that are not
advocating for our pleasure at all so
yeah the worry that we're not going to
get there which is why I teach a lot of
mindfulness okay meditation meditation
I'm telling you meditate and learn how
to learn the skill set of
bring yourself back to the present
moment and I also give a lot of tools
and smart sex to how to bring yourself
back to the moment during sex so you can
be present so you can breathe so you can
connect with your partner I mean there
have been times too where I'm just you
know when I give these examples too it's
like I just sex sometimes starts to
happen and you lose your weight you're
like you're in your head or you're like
did I turn the oven off did I and it's
okay like here's everything sex is not
so precious you're allowed to say you
know what let's stop for a second I'm
gonna run to the bathroom or I'm gonna
do something or let's breathe for a
minute sometimes again it's just going
I'm like oh God I I'm not here I'm not
present I've left the building and then
I'll just stop and I'll and I advocate
for this I'll do this my relationship
but I'll say can we just look each other
and breathe can we just like dude five
deep breaths for our inhales or as our
exhales a little bit longer than our
inhales and we breathe and we look into
each other's eyes and like we reset and
then you start again so I think again
this misinformation that sex is sort of
of a Sprint and not a marathon and that
we all it's very linear
we make out we take our clothes off we
have sex it's just not the case and it
makes it so Less Fun
Emily Moss ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do where should they go
definitely the release of podcast called
sex then we twice a week my
all my social media text to Emily and my
new book is smart sex you can buy it
wherever you buy books and uh you can
take my sex IQ quiz on my website that
will allow you know where to start on
your sexual Journey
Emily I appreciate you thank you
appreciate you too thanks for having me
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace